hello everyone welcome back to this new
session by simply learn
today in this video let's get to know in
detail about google analytics for
google analytics is a web analytics
service offered by google
it was launched back in 2005
it tracks and reports website traffic
from the information through wikipedia
google analytics is the most used web
analytics service as per the sources in
april 2022
google analytics was used by 73 percent
of the 10 000 most popular website
across the globe
however as per the reports from
beltway.com
two crore 81 lakh 52
477 live websites use google analytics
so now this is the time to understand
what has been changed in google
analytics over the years
if you are new to google analytics it's
even better
before moving forward
do subscribe to simply learn and hit the
bell icon to never miss any updates from
simply learn so what makes google
analytics so important
google analytics generates various types
of reports and helps to track bounce
rates identify the best content
of your website record user behavior
flow on your site and many other
metrics thereby allowing you to
understand and build your business
strategies
thereby growing your business
now that you have understood why google
analytics is essential
let's check what we have for you in this
video
first we will understand what is google
analytics for
then we will move forward with
identifying google analytics version for
your website
next we will have a detailed look at
universal analytics and google analytics
4.
we will continue by understanding
success stories from google analytics
for users
and finally we will end this session by
understanding the future of google
analytics poll
so allow me to introduce the next
generation of google analytics
google analytics for
also known as ga4 initially google
analytics 4 was known as apple's web
google analytics 4 is the latest
analytics property with several
advantages over the old google analytics
also known as universal analytics
understanding more clearly google
analytics sport can measure and keep
track of website traffic as well as app
usage so now you can imagine that google
analytics 4 is the one-stop solution for
all your analytics needs
if you are still using universal
analytics we recommend you to get
familiar with google analytics for as
well
as this is the new future of analytics
we will understand creating and setting
up google analytics for account in
detail in the upcoming videos
let's first identify
which google analytics property is
associated with your website
in order to identify which google
analytics property you have
login to your google analytics account
now
go to analytics account
and then open properties and apps
here you can see properties for your
website
now below the properties and apps
several properties are listed
where
you can see different ids
if the id starts with ua
and ends with a number
then you have a universal analytics
property
however if id only has numbers
like here
then you have google analytics for
property
we will learn how to switch the
universal analytics account to google
analytics 4 in the upcoming videos
now that you have understood how to
identify google analytics property
let's take a detailed look at the
comparison of universal analytics data
and google analytics 4 data
the major difference between universal
analytics and google analytics spore is
the measurement model
universal analytics uses sessions and
page views as the measurement model
whereas google analytics 4 uses events
and parameters as the measurement model
therefore any hit type from universal
analytics property say a page view user
timing etc are captured as event in
google analytics for property
let's see the detailed comparison
of every aspect of universal analytics
and google analytics sport
first we go with events
in analytics every measurable action for
example page load form completion
scrolls app installs etc is measured as
event
an event has category
label
and action in universal analytics
moreover it has its own hit type
in case of google analytics 4 there is
no categorization all the hit types from
universal analytics are considered as
events
now let's find the comparison of
universal analytics and google analytics
4 in terms of page views
page views is a metric defined that
calculates total number of pages viewed
on your website
now let's get a better understanding of
page views
for instance when user lands on the web
page of your site
the page loads
this is considered to be a page view
now suppose if user reloads the page
google analytics tracks it as another
page view
if the user navigates to another page of
your website and returns to the same
page
this adds another page view to your site
now that you have understood page views
let's see how page views differs
in universal analytics and google
analytics sport
from universal analytics page view are
translated to google analytics for
property
as page view event
this page view event
automatically gets triggered in google
tag manager
the next metric we have
is sessions
session is a time duration for which
user is active on your website
a universal analytics session may
consist of multiple page views
events
e-commerce transactions etc
the session is considered to be ended if
the user has 30 minutes of inactivity or
any other event for which session end is
triggered
in google analytics 4 session metrics
are tracked from session start event
which automatically gets triggered with
the basic interaction on your website
however the session duration depends on
the period between the first and the
last event
now let's check our next metric which is
custom dimension
in universal analytics custom dimension
add the information to the collected
data
whereas in google analytics 4
information is added through the event
parameters
moving ahead
the next metric we have is content
grouping
content grouping in universal analytics
allows to group content into a logical
structure
after which one can view and compare
metrics by the group name
now talking about google analytics 4 it
has predefined event parameter for
content group this parameter fills the
data into content group moving ahead
the next metric we have is client id
client id is a unique string generated
randomly and acts as a pseudonomous
identifier
client id identifies the browser
instance and then it gets stored in the
browser cookies
and therefore subsequent visits to the
same site are associated with that user
in both
universal analytics and google analytics
for
client id serves the same purpose
that is the client id is responsible for
providing the identifier
now let's move ahead with our next
metric
parameters
parameters are associated with google
analytics for properties
understanding in detail about parameters
parameters are the chunk of information
that specifies the user action
for example parameters can be passed
to describe the value of the purchase
next we have is user property
user properties provide information like
preferred language or geographical
location of the users that interact with
your website or app
now that we have seen difference between
universal analytics and google analytics
four properties
the question definitely arises
can google analytics really bring
success to your business
well if you have a good understanding of
your audience and have extraordinary
strategies to work on the google
analytics is your best companion
here are some success stories by google
analytics for users
we all know about mcdonald's the leading
fast food cooperation with huge number
of outlets across the globe
recently a case study has been shared by
mcdonald's hong kong
which suggests that the company has
experienced growth in conversions by 550
through the in-app orders
and what made them achieve such a great
growth
yes you guessed it right it's google
analytics 4.
let's have a look on their success story
the major goal for the company was to
redesign the strategy to increase in-app
food orders
predict the behavior of in-app audiences
and reach the right customers with
mcdonald's mobile order campaigns to
achieve the goals mcdonald used a simple
yet smart approach and implemented
google analytics pool properties with
the help of predictive audiences in
google analytics pool properties they
tried converting audiences into
customers
moreover with the help of google ads
they were able to manage the campaigns
as a result of the smart efforts
mcdonald was able to gain increase in
conversions by 550 percent for the users
who are likely to purchase in next seven
days
isn't it amazing
moreover for the same audience
mcdonald's had noticed a visible
decrease in cost per action by 63
percent
and an increase in revenue by 560
percent
some other companies that have seen
growth in their business through google
analytics sport includes pepsico
claroshop etc
with the proven success of top brands in
the world let us know what the future of
google analytics 4 holds as per the
reports on bildewood.com
there are two crore 81 lakh 52
477 live websites that are using google
analytics
out of which there are one crore 21 lakh
seventy three thousand four hundred and
thirteen live websites from usa
and four lakh sixty eight thousand five
hundred thirty eight live websites from
india
who are using google analytics if we
look in detail
we have a list of big names like bank of
america
blogger.com
cisco
netflix
coursera
flipkart
icici bank
tesla india
irctc
myntra etc that are using google
analytics for their growth
however we are all well aware of the
success stories of all the biggies on
the list
thus google analytics will continue to
be an important part of new business
strategies
things you should know before we end
this session are
google analytics 4 will be soon
replacing universal analytics
from 1 july 2023
the universal analytics platform will be
no longer in action
however you will be able to access the
reports for some period of time
google analytics 4 will be the new
future of analytics so here i would like
to end this video with a hearty promise
to come back with another interesting
topic related to seo
if you like this video do subscribe to
our channel simply learn and press the
bell icon to never miss any updates from
simplyland thanks for watching this
video and stay tuned with us
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here